Donald Trump is trying to find a
replacement for Obamacare probably one
where I'm going to guess cancer patients
are prescribed a round of golf and if is
a two strip club buffet but it's proving
to be tougher than he thought take a
look now I have to tell you it's an
unbelievably complex subject nobody knew
that healthcare could be so complicated
nobody know no one any good idea the
total out of the blue we got sideswiped
with the complexity of health care our
favorite reaction the presidency
wilderness came from Bernie Sanders who
did this on CNN
I don't know if you guys are going to
get this reference but this reminds me
of the preacher from poltergeist - ha ha
ha Burnie looks great so much color on
his face
it looks like a beautiful little
strawberry that you got caught in a
spider web comedian plus the last thing
that made Bernie laugh like this Henry
Chris I want to correct you he's not
actually laughing he's having a heart
attack
Angela when he remembers he can get rock
hard erections all right I was not
expecting the space work right after
that everybody's a bad bunch Brendan
when he successfully sent Marty home by
harnessing a lightning bolt all right
any to place two gigawatt know it's a
1.21 gigawatts 1.21 gigawatts